- Let's wrap up this hour
with one last feel-good story,
sure to bring you some joy.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Y'all meet 10 year-old Caiden.
With his mastery of double
back flips and double whips,
he's already a champion BMX athlete,
racking up big wins worldwide
against kids as old as 16.
He's 10 and he's just
getting started y'all.
Caiden's now set his sights on
the X Games and the Olympics.
We have this young man with big talent
on the line right now.
What's up, Caiden.
(audience cheering)
- Kelly.
- Oh my gosh.
First of all, congratulations,
I'm so proud of you.
This is so awesome, you're killing it.
And I gotta ask you, how
did you get into BMX?
- So, my dad would always go
to the dirt bike track and stuff with me.
So, I would used to ride my PW,
my little dirt bike when I was one,
and then ever since I rode my dirt bike,
I just go straight to my push bike.
- Oh my gosh.
The one picture of you flying
in the air like Superman.
How does your mom deal with that?
That's scary, man.
Oh my gosh, you're so high in the air.
You're unbelievable.
So, I hear you're working on
new tricks right now, right?
- Yeah, I'm trying to do triple whips,
flare bars,
triple back flips.
- What?
Oh my gosh.
(audience applauding)
You are incredible, I love it.
You're so fearless.
Thank you so much, Caiden.
We're all just watching
you, we're supporting you,
and we're rooting for you, alright?
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
- Alright, I'm liking
your posts right now.
And that's not all,
our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
they want to honor ultimate overachievers,
just like you, my man.
So, they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How does that sound?
(audience cheering)
- A thousand?
Oh my gosh, that's so good.
- Absolutely.
- [Caiden] That means so much.
- We are so proud of you,
Caiden, keep killing it.